Okay, you're doing great. You've really learned a lot of powerful mathematics in the last 20 minutes,
so let's think how we're going to use this.
It doesn't seem to make sense to keep calculating the sine of 37 degrees
every single time we encounter a triangle with a 37 degree angle.
This number is never changing. This sine will always be 3/5.
What they did in Eratosthenes' day was calculate large tables of trigonometric ratios.
They would find the sine, cosine, and tangent of a variety of angles and save it away
for future reference--here's an example table of trigonometric ratios.
In the columns, we have sine, cosine, and tangent and we have these values computed for,
well just a few degrees here--40, 41, 42 degrees.
In a better table, we'd have a larger range of angles and higher resolutions
so we'd have 40.1 degrees, 40.2 degrees, and so on, but this will work for now.
What this table allows us to do is something really amazing, so let's say we have a triangle and
it's a right triangle with an angle here of 42 degrees and let's say we know this length its 1000 meters.
How can I find this length? This is something we haven't done yet.
What I can do is say, "Ah, I know that the ratio of this side to this side is
totally independent of how long these sides actually are. "
In fact, this side being adjacent to 42 degrees and this side being hypotenuse
looks like we're going to want to use a cosine which compares adjacent to hypotenuse.
In fact what I can say is that the cosine of 42 degrees which I can look up in my table is 0.743
must be equal to the adjacent side, I'll call that x for now, over the hypotenuse
and the hypotenuse is the length of 1000 meters.
This is a huge, huge tool to have because now all we have to do is multiply by 1000 to solve for x
and we find that x is equal to 743 meters.
Now I'm going to give you a shot. Let's call this unknown length y.
Can you go through a similar set of steps may be you won't be using cosine this time
to figure out how long is this side y.